hello everybody
my name is wonderful german it's tim
messerschmitt
i hate it
and today my talk is going to be open
identity
getting to know your users
and basically the cool stuff that you
can do with that
so as i got mentioned already i'm a
developer evangelist at paypal
and whenever i turn up at the jscom for
something people like what paper really
so what does paypal actually do at js
conf
paper used to be
a bank right like
that's one of those companies running c
c plus plus in their back ends having
really awkward uis and stuff like that
that was with our old ceo so then a new
guy called david marcus joined that
being a startup guy
and he decided let's throw all of that
stuff away and hire some great people so
we had people like doug crockford
joining us we've got bill scott now with
us and those guys decided to create
something amazing so our new backend is
basically running on node.js we use dust
for data binding we use backbone so lots
of cool stuff that you guys use in your
project are now running on our scale as
well
so
about my talk
first of all
you can go to developerpaypal.com but
this is not going to be about paper
products now this is going to be about
different open identity technology
that's
of1a open id connect open id browser id
all that stuff
that helps you to create great user
experience so what really is identity
i think the best way to explain anything
is
using lego and using ninjas
so
i heard it yeah thanks
so
on the interwebs i can be whoever i want
right like
i go to a web service i go to any site i
register my account and i say my name is
mr t i'm wearing big golden chains i
don't like flying around i'm basically
part of the a-team
how can you prove that
you can't really right
also for some use cases i want to really
be me because
it might be that this is closely uh
connected to things like shipping items
to me
and then i want to make sure that i
really prove my identity
so these are some of the things that i'm
talking about and also i want to talk
about how to bring this technology how
to bring stuff like oauth into not just
be logging in context but also into
stuff like api communication
so
if you have any questions during the
talk feel free to reach out to me but
also i'll be available after this
session to discuss anything
so
lots of people
use identity always the same way
they go to a web service where they use
a mobile application and what they do is
they use twitter google plus or facebook
all the time mostly even the same
service the reason for that is they
don't really care they just share their
details and they want to log in quickly
right
the issue is
should we really do that
like
should you always expose the same
identity and does it always make sense
to use the same identity
i don't really think so
also i want to cover
some slight annoyances that i see people
often confuse the topic authentication
versus authorization
so authentication
that's what you might expect from stuff
like open id browser id
so
authentication technology is about
proving that the person logging in at
the service or the person using
resources is actually you
so that's really about identity
while authorization
is mostly about sharing resources so
that could be
your direct messages as twitter that
could be your google plus stream that
could be lots of different stuff like
facebook image upload
anything that basically can do
interactions with an api could be a
resource
the issue is
due to the
mixed up nature and messed up nature of
identity products often authorization
gets misused to use
basically to authentication
so that is something like an endpoint
slash profile me something like that
that works kinda but it's not like how
it should be
so let's have a look at the current
standards in order to understand where
we are
what's coming up and what you maybe
should rethink
so basic off is quite known right like
we pass it as a header and then we have
um the base 64 encoding or you can pass
it in the url this is basically really
like passing your client id and the
secret your username and password
anything like that
that was kind of suitable but it's not
really secure
now
in 2007 the final draft for something of
one got released
whoever implemented orof1
who liked it
see
same happened to me so
my background is actually i'm coming
from the android world and i was forced
to do some javascript and i
it really turned out i kind of liked it
and
while on android it was really fit
because it was java that you had to use
on javascript you at least have amazing
libraries nowadays like passport that
help you
but still
of one is kind of clunky
so
lots of interesting people like aaron
hammer were included in this erin hammer
was one of the contributors at iatf
and
you will see this name later on with
slides
so lots of companies like twitter yahoo
google
started to use of1 because it allows
users to actually use their google
account at other services to use data
from that
so basically it allowed to have a much
nicer login experience
and
login experience is really something
that matters
now
sadly in 2009 there was
a big issue we come to that
but first of all let's have a look at
the flow it's totally convenient
so people first of all have to request
something they call a request token
that's on the consumer which is
basically client side
and you have on the right side the
service provider so that might be
twitter that might be google facebook
whatever you want
now after this token got generated and
got returned to the consumer
the user is going to be
redirected to the service provider he
has to log in
then depending on the flow he might get
something which was called oob which was
basically a code that you could copy
paste into another window again
or you could use something they call
verification code
basically to obtain the authorization so
user logs in says yes this application
should definitely have all my images
so i login then this funny authorization
token gets generated
and on my consumer site i'm going to
exchange that thing for something we
call access token so again we talk to
the service provider and the service
provider make sure that this is still
the valid user
sounds kind of good right and then with
the access token being returned to my
consumer i can do things like requesting
resources
so far so good
but of one had some flaws
initially
the client got the redirect uri so
where basically the service provider
should lead you after doing things like
the authorization in the second step
so the user got redirected to the site
that you
provided
but what if
a counter attack would be done so people
could actually
use this redirect uri
and get the needed authorization code
and basically hijack your identity which
is not really nice
so
they came up in with this thing called
of one dot a or 1.0 a whatever you like
and the idea was
we moved this now into the first step so
you cannot just easily modify the oauth
flow and therefore it's much more secure
and actually it kind of worked
but having a look at this
it's kind of complex there's a lot of
steps involved
and the issue is
this was not really designed with things
like mobile in mind this was not
designed with things like embedded
systems in mind so it had to be
simplified and there had to be more
scenarios
so of2 came up so this was definitely
focused on simplicity this was focused
on things like different scenarios
the final framework got basically
released in 2012
and everything seemed to be amazing it
uses bearer tokens which basically are
used to do the authorization via the
header
it was much easier than of one because
of one without using a library on the
client side was a huge pain
so whoever implemented of2 client-side
did you like it more than oauth1
it's much easier really
basically if you understand how to set
one single header that's it that's all
you need it's much easier
sadly
there were again issues
let's have a look at the flow
so
instead of doing something like
generating this request token that's
kind of not really is authorized we
direct the user immediately to the
service
again we obtain the authorization
again we
get the access token and we use that
thing to request resources like your
profile and stuff like that
so
they got rid of one whole step so there
is this thing called free leg or off and
there's this thing called two-legged
oauth and that's basically what you see
over here so if you depend uh basically
compare this
against this
it's much easier
and this is why you don't have to fiddle
around so much with libraries anymore
because
it got basically designed with easiness
in mind
now the issue again is
of2 was designed initially beginning of
2009 2010 iitf is kind of big
as a group lots of companies are being
involved
so one guy last year released a really
angry blog post
who saw that on hacker news
so aaron hammer
basically being one of the main guys
behind the whole of one thing behind the
or
of two thing at some point decided this
is all crap
so they've been designing this one big
solution that should help
corporates that should have startups
that should help
independent developers to quickly create
things like
the authorization for your service
the big issue was
there was very basically too many
scenarios and too many people involved
and
so his big statement was
that while of2 basically being nice it's
more than a
it's just a blueprint so basically it
tells you you could do it like that you
could do it like that but it's not
really being concrete while the of one
spec specs were really concrete in
nearly all details so aaron was really
pissed off
and that's right
so there's another guy
who does lots of
blog posts about security who does lots
of things like buck hunting
his name is igor hummakov
and
he wrote this other big blog post about
of2 being basically a huge huge attack
surface
because there's things like the access
token
so
the the
initial thought behind an access token
is once you have that thing
you do stuff like um you throw it
against the server to get direct
messages you throw it again
this server to do things like posting
and you tweet
everything that you basically do works
with the same access token
but that thing doesn't really expire
so
if somebody manages to get your cookie
and he has access once to your access
token
he has access to all your resources and
that's not really great right
so
people came up with the idea
they could make expiring tokens
but that doesn't still really
solve the problem right because it
doesn't really matter to me if i have
two minutes access to your resources or
10 hours if i have access i can get your
resources
so there were lots of different
discussions going around uh of two being
not secure enough and of two being
secure enough
and
basically what you will see is if you
have a look at companies that use off to
like twitter and facebook
or even us as paper
lots of them do lots of server sides
modifications around this blueprint
so
security implementations
are possible but the protocol doesn't
really tell you how so you need to be
really aware about how to do that
now
we basically have now the
big nice authorization
so we could get
resources
but initially oaf was meant to be
something anonymous
so whenever i log in
using oauth
i don't want to grant you my username
not my password i don't want to fill in
lots of details
but at some point you might need that
because you want to
implement a nice user interface saying
hi tim it's amazing to see you
your black hair looks great stuff like
that i don't know
so
identification matters
and
details like having a name date of birth
creation date i don't know like anything
that could be
closely coupled to your account
can be valuable
now
especially things like creation dates
for accounts are interesting because
you could think about
is an account that got created one hour
ago as valid as an account that got
created four years ago
and the interesting thing about this is
scopes are being used to define the
resources that you want to access or the
attributes so scopes can be either
static
so you define them once and your
application always gets the same data
or scopes can be dynamic
so
while you basically do the
authentication part you can define that
you want to have a profile the profile
plus via email things like that there's
different ways to define that because
oauth2 gives you the freedom to define
stuff
and lots of companies really do it
different so
this is
actually not a bad idea right
now identity products had a few issues
open id
it was meant to be amazing because it
was meant to
really identify you
was developed in 2005
so it's kind of old again
in 2012 there was one big
bug being discovered which allowed to
hijack authentication
so it was not really secure anymore
and really just a few days ago gen rain
announced that they stopped to use
myopemid.com
so your central one identity for the
internet might be shut down
so open iv while being
intentionally right about proving that
it's you
had this big flaw
it was really difficult to implement the
spec was huge because it had things in
there like auto discoverability
and it kind of didn't work
so identity still matters to lots of
companies and one company came up with a
solution called browser id or persona
named mozilla
and that thing was launched in 2011.
they brought a new feature out called
identity bridging which allows every
google mail user to log in at this one
century service which might be again
some central identity service
browser id being baked in into your
browser in firefox and i think there's
also libraries for other browsers
and persona being the one central
service in the web
so we've learned that there's
authentication and we've learned there's
authorization
but
how to combine them both like really
nicely not just being an off hack
so
the first solution was to come up with
open id with an extension for
oauth which they call of hybrid
extension that thing got drafted down in
2009
but it relied on of one so
by definition it was [ __ ] to implement
and sadly
there were all these flaws like the of
one flaw
so
why you basically had access to
resources and identity
it
depended on a bad
structure so it was not really great to
use
and then there is open id connect which
is still a draft but it gets lots of
things right so openid connect is based
on of2
and that's nice for the authorization
part
and it adds a big identity layer on top
of that in order to make sure that you
get
a really nice resource friendly rest api
friendly access to resources like your
profile
and one of the interesting things is
that they
implemented something they call session
management
so on oauth usually if you want to log
out as a user you have to go to a
settings page somewhere hidden in the
service and you have to revoke token
access
lots of people don't really know what it
does so they just leave applications b
forever
and that's not really the best way to do
it so on open id connect using this
session management basically you have an
additional endpoint
slash logout or whatever you want to
name it
that
you can have in your ui that you can
have as a user
to end your own session and basically
avoid your token so the token that
somebody stole it in a database or
wherever he stored it
cannot be used to access new information
anymore
so that's quite nice and also i think
needed
now
i've been mentioning different identity
providers i've been mentioning the
social ones like twitter like facebook
like google those are amazing for lots
of different use cases like games you
see companies like soundcloud
implementing that that's awesome but
sometimes
in use cases like e-commerce that's
where we come from you need more
concrete data because anybody can put
anything on facebook right
and
so you always have to think about
concrete data
that you can use in your ui to
improve user experience and also the
nice thing about concrete data is you
can rely on it being verified because
usually
as an example if i log in at ebay with
my paypal account and i have the wrong
shipping address because i skipped lots
of big parts in the registration or
something like that
somebody else gets my package and nobody
gets it so it doesn't really help
one thing that i hate and that i really
discover nowadays and lots of services
are artificial barriers
so
that applies not just to the web but
also to native apps
you go to the website and it says log in
with facebook login whatever provider
you want
and if you don't you cannot use the
service i call that an artificial
barrier because
you kind of make sure that this
gatekeeper
keeps out all the users but some users
just want to have a sneak peek of your
service want to understand what you
actually really do
and so it makes sense to
don't force all these resource-sharing
things you want to encourage it so you
say if you log in again then you get all
your friends showing up and stuff
but at least make sure they can see some
of your service before
now i've been talking a lot about
about the single sign-on techniques
about oauth and stuff
and you might think yeah nice
but why should i actually really use it
so now i come up with numbers
um people forget passwords
there was this consultancy called
blueing and they basically did the
survey asking
if somebody would
type in a security question or would
email his old password to his email
account or something like that basically
resetting your password kind of things
and only 45 percent
really said
if i have to do that i'm not going to
come back again
people don't like to use passwords
anymore they like to use
services that they have anyway
because
if i defined all my properties and
attributes like my birthday my email
address and all that stuff i don't want
to come up with that stuff again
it's basically
slowing me down because i want to access
your information
and also especially when you're mobile
there might be so much
problems with error pro error prone data
so if i have to enter my email address
it might be wrong because i was in
youtube
stuff like that
just try to speed up things
there is another fact
people think that social sign is
actually desirable
they have these profiles please use them
offer to use them at least
now i've been talking about the whole
user experience thing it's nice that you
use it and stuff but where else can you
use authentication
now for you javascript guys jsonp might
be known i hope so
so
for cross-domain requests like getting
different scripts from other web
services
usually you use either a course or jsonp
and now you want to secure this
communication and
because jsonp
is basically an attack vector because
you open up your site to
scripts and callbacks from other sites
you want to secure that so that's where
you can come in with basic off again you
saw that mike west spoke about things
like the nons that you can pass for
scripts
those techniques really have to use
authentication in order to make sure
that your server stays
really not attacked nice and defensed
now of course who knows course
awesome
so
especially in the payment scene right
now course is a thing there's this thing
going on they call pci compliance so
whenever you accept credit card data in
your service you need to be pci
compliant which means you have to store
data in a predefined way you need to be
certified which costs a lot of money and
companies like stripe came up with
techniques that allow you to basically
pass data directly to them
and
we didn't do the same with our api lots
of other companies nowadays use
cross-origin request sharing
which basically makes sure that you have
something that works against the same
origin policy
and again this is where you could use
things like of2
so
our api is an example that now uses
the authorization bearer token thing
to basically pass a header with of2
to make sure that the payments api call
is secure
so
this is basically really easy you do
things like um
you do a basic authentication to get the
earth token and then you use your off
token to do any payments calls
lots of companies do that and i think
it's actually kind of smart to use the
same technique for that
now
for course
you do things like modifying the xhr by
setting the access control headers
so
in your request you say where the origin
comes from so that could be your server
that could be any other server
and you say which other servers are
allowed
so you say that that these access
control headers
are set and therefore the api bob.com
thing from html5 rocks
enables you to get data back from that
and that's amazing that really helps
so if you want to have a look at apis
that use that you can go to github.com
github the user set for their api
and i think it's kind of a good
technology and a trend that
is desirable
now
wrapping up things
i think there's a big difference between
authentication and authorization and
people shouldn't just use of2 to
hack identification into their products
identity obviously matters so it makes
sense to not just offer one identity
provider but several of them
and also you might want to think about
things like token-based api
communication to see secure your client
server communication
don't keep your users out and now i'm
really
happy to have qa
thanks
you